[Music]
israel had one of the world's fastest
vaccination campaigns
over 60 percent of the population is
fully inoculated
but then came the delta variant and now
emergency wards are starting to fill up
again
the health ministry says a fresh round
of vaccination is needed to keep the new
strain at bay
therefore those who received the vaccine
five or six months ago
need to get a third dose
and without a third dose they are far
less protected
and this is what we are doing now
we are the first in the world to do this
once again israel is forging ahead and
their success or failure will provide
valuable data to the rest of the world
working to contain the delta strain
this is your kovid 19 special here on dw
i'm jenelle dumalaon
most israelis living in one of the most
vaccinated countries on the planet
thought the worst of kovid 19 was behind
them but now the fourth wave has come
forcing covidwards back into action
the medical staff at tel aviv's ichilov
hospital are back in crisis mode nurse
iman shows us around the intensive care
unit for covet 19 patients
the award had to be reopened a month ago
it is at full capacity again as the
delta variant plunges israel deep into a
fourth wave
the isolation ward is a stark reminder
that the pandemic is far from over
it goes without saying it takes a lot
out of us it's not a regular award it's
difficult with all the seriously ill
patients
you need to be able to deal with it
it's very upsetting i was hoping that we
wouldn't get back to this
i just started working in the hospital a
month and a half ago but i really wanted
to
work in the corona ward and be part of
it
a majority of the seriously ill patients
on this covet 19 ward have not been
vaccinated
some have been inoculated but still got
infected here it's mostly elderly people
back outside we meet dr tashbina the
vaccines work and are vitally important
he says without them more people would
get seriously ill but the effectiveness
of the vaccine seems to wane over time
and there the many coronavirus variants
to contend with you have
two processes one process is the
disappearance of antibodies
with time with the time
along with the time along with months i
mean six seven months eight months
you have to make a booster
on top of it you have a new variant
which is more aggressive
and then you have to compete with two
processes at the same time
israel was one of the first countries to
start its vaccination campaign last
december about 60
of the population has been vaccinated by
now the vast majority with two shots
the sudden reversal is a critical test
for the new government restrictions are
back and forth masks must be worn
indoors travel rules have been tightened
the unvaccinated are being urged to get
their job
the government is pinning its hopes on a
third booster shot although the
effectiveness is still under debate more
than a million israelis over 50 have
already had a third shot
people here in israel are pro
vaccination they know they know and they
feel that they help us in the first time
so they are willing to do it again they
are trusting the science behind it
israel's authorities are trying to
strike a difficult balance tightening
restrictions while at the same time
encouraging booster vaccinations
in the hope of heading off a full
lockdown
here er lewis joins us now he's an
israeli scientist and physician welcome
to the program now israel was one of the
first countries to successfully pull off
a mass vaccination effort quickly as we
heard there is what is happening there a
taste of things to come for other
countries who followed its lead
well i think what we've learned with the
19 that it's
extremely unexpected and you should
prepare for the unexpected but that
being said i think that trends have been
similar in different countries
similarly to how israel has perhaps
followed the uk with the
delta surge here so so yes it could be
a pre-signal for other countries
can you tell us why israel is
experiencing such high infection rates
despite widespread vaccination is it
really just down to delta
so
like the you said in the piece before
the interview there are actually two
processes here going on first of all
it's delta and what's
most people think both scientists think
is that's actually uh not the most
important factor but there probably is
also a of of waning immunity and there's
been a lot of talk about it lately
there's actually a very good paper that
came out yesterday from israel and which
summarizes data summarizes data nicely
and it
fits in with what was we were seeing
from the data coming out of the uk in
the u.s there was a paper published in
the u.s
also a few days ago that showed that
vaccine effectiveness versus infection
definitely
wanes over time but the important thing
is and this is what we're also seeing in
israel is the effectiveness for severe
disease perhaps go down goes down a
little but it is still very high
probably over 85 to 90 percent for most
age groups does this mean booster shots
are essential for countries that are
seeing infections like these
you know that's an excellent question
chanel and probably the question that
everyone is asking themselves so first
of all i'd like to say that you know for
for many vaccines uh the regular
schedule of the of the immunization
protocol includes a booster shot let's
say for hepatitis b you get the vaccine
and then you get another one after a
month and then you get another one after
six months so this isn't not it is
biologically plausible um antibodies do
good
but uh obviously antibodies and and the
blood do not tell the entire picture
because uh
b cells memory cells which are
generating antibodies still exist but
the bottom line is that booster shots
may be needed um
we would have to collect more
information from what's going on in
israel right now
i think to determine the effectiveness
of the booster shot
what we're seeing in israel right now is
that after uh the booster uh
protocol was initiated in the older
people uh then the rates of severe cases
uh started turning down as opposed to
the rate of cases and the unvaccinated
population and what percentage of that
is the behavioral change as older people
have realized that the surge is real and
they need to be more careful and what
percentage of that
is actually the effect of the booster
we're going to need to wait for more raw
data and to be analyzed and uh and
published before that can be reliably
said i think
much to be determined but what does this
fourth wave in a widely vaccinated
population population like israel's mean
for the goal of herd immunity
i think herd immunity you know has been
a sort of a catchphrase that's been used
a lot and and perhaps also misused a lot
over the past year and a half
um it's difficult to say what herd
immunity means because especially
um as as as said you know new variants
perhaps um less amenable to or
less susceptible to vaccines uh
i i on to be honest i don't know what it
means for her it means and i don't think
anyone knows
right yeah you're luis thank you very
much erie lewis is an israeli scientist
and physician thanks for your time today
sure thank you
up next our science correspondent derek
williams answers one of your questions
what makes a pandemic a pandemic covet
19 is one but the flu apparently isn't
why
this is pretty confusing i admit so so
maybe it's best to start with some basic
definitions um the first term
used in connection with the appearance
of a disease whether it's caused by a
novel pathogen or by a pathogen we've
seen before
is outbreak
which is kind of a catch-all description
for any
sudden rise in the number of cases
outbreaks can happen in a particular
geographic region
but they can also cross international
borders um they can occur
unexpectedly or or or intermittently
like for example ebola outbreaks in
parts of sub-saharan africa
or they can be regular occurrences like
seasonal outbreaks of flu
an epidemic on the other hand describes
the situation when an outbreak expands
and the disease begins spreading quickly
to
a large number of people
both within individual countries and
across international borders um the sars
epidemic of 2002 and 2003 which was
eventually contained after killing
hundreds of people
it's often cited as an example of an
epidemic
a pandemic
is what an epidemic turns into when it
spins out of control and infecting an
even larger number of people
at an expanding rate and hitting
populations globally
ratcheting up the number of deaths in in
a big way um often that kind of wildfire
spread occurs
because the pathogen is a new one or is
is maybe one that's reappeared suddenly
after a long hiatus um so most people
have never been exposed to it before and
and have no immunity um flu pandemics do
occur regularly just think of the one
that killed between 50 and 100 million
people worldwide
over a three-year period
after the end of the first world war
um however that was caused by a novel
flu virus that was quite different
than the flu viruses circulating in
populations at the time causing
normal levels of endemic flu um those
endemic flu bugs also cause disease of
course and and they also kill people
but mostly
seasonally in different parts of the
world and and in relatively predictable
numbers
which is what distinguishes them in
epidemiological terms from for instance
a pandemic causing pathogen
like soros kofi 2.
[Music]
and that was our covid19 special thanks
for watching stay safe and see you again
soon
[Music]
you